leave me alone all i said is we should
bail on the hike i didn't mean us in
general i just meant the hype you don't
want to make our relationship better our
relationship is fine
it's bad church bells
shmigadoon
[Music]
must be something they do for tourists
hey everyone hey there pete
can we go now already
what we can't leave
it's like magic we're in an actual
musical
please god damn
[Music]
[Applause]
do everybody said we're only here till
we found true love
do you think this is true love what does
that even mean who knows what schmidtoon
thinks is true love
which of you ladies wants to cross this
bridge with me you want to try with
other people
what a beautiful couple you two mate
stop it you are
stunning compared to you i have a
barefoot mess ah
let's go find your shoes
we're stuck here forever you're just
going to give up we're smart we found
our way out of ikea
we'll find a way out of here ladies can
i get a cackle
[Music]
we're in a musical okay nobody gets
killed in a musical except oklahoma
and carousel and south pacific oh hello
west side story that's all the musicals
you